[Applaudissements]
[Musique] l'
éducation civique est une mère de table commune est décédée
pendant la circonstance et nous nous sommes annoncés
il y a deux ans aniket Elio maintenance sur
Domini
ce que j'ai vu c'était d'après mon expérience
les décisions étaient en grande partie
motivées par des raisons financières le conseil était dirigé par des banquiers
s'il vous plaît permettez  son fils pour écouter cela
disait généralement que l'entreprise coiffait de la dentelle pauvre
toute la noblesse l'entreprise a-t-elle senti que les
retraités c'est juste une question affreuse le
coup final est venu en janvier lorsque les derniers
magasins Sears les ont fermés cela a laissé des
milliers d'employés et de retraités
inquiets pour leurs pensions très
possible
ohto dans la ville d'Apollo Monte Oscar
Newman du tout pour moi
nous pouvons nous contenir le plus demandé
au monde depuis des années Sears Batali a
vu le déficit de ses fonds de pension augmenter
en même temps les
actionnaires de Sears ont empoché des milliards
ils l'aiment seul le soleil apne la
décision ainsi  comme je dis toute cette merde
ils ont tout fait pour sauver leurs
pensions mais au final tout le monde les a
laissé tomber alors mesure ano  l'autre indice pour l'
instant Jane aujourd'hui j'ai tellement
[Musique]
qui aurait pensé qu'après 65
ans le géant de la vente au détail se replierait avec
son célèbre catalogue et ses
prouesses technologiques Sears était l'Amazone des
années 1970 et 80 mécano sanglant cinglé s22
Jolie charlatan UMI's à l'époque  Sears
Canada était une filiale du
géant américain Sears Roebuck ce qui va
vous aider Jamal au coeur de Chicago la
Sears Tower symbolisait le pouvoir de l'
entreprise
assis sur la PACU sur un littéralement le
premier ministre ne peut tolérer notre appel
Alexis Larry Moore travaillait à  Sears pendant
plus de 30 ans pendant la moitié de ce temps en tant que
vice-président en 2005, les choses ont commencé à
changer et il a décidé de prendre sa retraite aux
États-Unis.  un fonds spéculatif a pris le contrôle de Sears,
ce qui signifiait que sa filiale canadienne
lui appartenait désormais également le
nouveau chef de l'entreprise était un multimilliardaire nommé
Eddie Lampert nous devions changer la
culture dont nous avions besoin pour changer notre
modèle d'exploitation à un moment donné et les choses ont
commencé à  changer rapidement le Canada Je prends
environ deux catégories II le
commerce des cartes de crédit était le ciment qui nous liait à
nos clients
marque Cohen était le patron de Larry
il dirigeait Sears Canada avant qu'il ne soit vendu
à Lampert le commerce des cartes de crédit était
une base énorme c'était une vache à lait
c'était toujours rentable, la vente de
l'activité de cartes de crédit était une
aubaine de deux virgule deux milliards de dollars pour l'
entreprise
Sears en a payé un virgule cinq milliards de
dollars à ses actionnaires et
plutôt que de réinvestir cet argent dans
l'entreprise comme le font la plupart des entreprises quand
elles  faire une cession consécutive il a
versé un dividende aux actionnaires et
il est le principal actionnaire
je pense que le commerce de détail je pense que ça va être
excellent dedans Eddie Lampert dit que
c'est le conseil d'administration de Sears Canada
qui a pris la décision de vendre l'
entreprise de cartes de crédit et il dit qu'il n'avait
aucune autorité sur le conseil, mais l'ex-PDG
Mark Cohen croit qu'Eddie Lampert
avait une certaine influence, il est un
critique de longue date de Lampert et de son
style de gestion aujourd'hui, il enseigne à l'
Université de Columbia et est un expert du
commerce de détail cela a commencé une série de
ventes d'actifs
qui ont commencé à encombrer de plus en plus les
entreprises paralyser les entreprises tuer
les entreprises des années de
réduction des coûts incessante signifiaient que  Sears est passé de l'
un des plus grands détaillants du pays
à l'ombre de ses anciens
investissements personnels nécessaires pour maintenir les magasins en
bon état de fonctionnement.
assalam est un magicien les acheteurs juteux
ont mal réagi et les ventes ont chuté c'était
une expérience un peu décourageante
david  's its m'a se spécialise dans le
redressement des entreprises de vente au détail en difficulté il a
été embauché comme vice-président chez Sears
en 2012 pour relancer la marque il n'avait pas l'
impression d'avoir le soutien du conseil d'administration il
était difficile d'amener les personnes clés à regarder
de leurs ordinateurs et prêter
attention à ce qui se passait ils
n'ont certainement pas projeté d'engagement dans
ce que nous essayions de faire ce qui s'est passé
à la fin de 2013 a surpris de nombreux
responsables de Sears plutôt que de
réinvestir massivement dans ses magasins Sears a payé
plus de cinq cents  millions de dollars de
dividendes aux actionnaires 2013 a été une année
très charnière, il reste encore beaucoup
à faire avec le recul pour que ce soit l'
année pour émettre de gros dividendes, on
dirait et ce n'est pas du tout cohérent
avec un groupe qui regarde vers l'
avenir de  cette entreprise, les retraités ont vu
leur sécurité financière s'effondrer,
tandis que les propriétaires d'actions de Sears Canada
étaient sur le point de profiter d'une aubaine au-dessus de vous
pasión redondante à la mi-automne,
elle ne peut pas vous pouvez accompagner avoir Apple
l'intention là-bas, notre pays voit l'
abrogation de l'origine, le
fonds de pension est entré en déficit a causé un peu de
diesel pompeux éloigné de nombreuses civettes une
assiette de FFA mais nous avons dit Andrew Michelle
Lizzy est un économiste à la retraite excuse les oreilles
sont rouges Ruth je vois des poussoirs sur notre
appel être un  une personne parfaitement équilibrée a
tué des navires xn nous tue tous les isms
devant visuellement plus fort entre 2005 et
2013, près de quatre milliards de dollars d'
actifs ont été vendus, dont 3,5 milliards ont été
distribués aux actionnaires, soit dix
fois plus que ce qui a été versé au cours de la
décennie précédente tout ce qu'il faisait
récoltait tout cet argent de l'
entreprise
David, c'est ma laissé l'entreprise
déçue maintenant je regarde en arrière et j'en lis
plus et c'est comme en fait c'est un
peu une parodie que c'était c'est
horrible comment tout cela s'est déroulé
les retraités maintenant  craignent le pire que l'
entreprise fasse faillite, laissant un gros
déficit de retraite et un revenu mensuel plus
faible pour eux, ils partagent leurs
préoccupations avec le
Commission des services financiers de l'Ontario est-ce une diva l'
application sportive ouverte
comportement de surveillance riche d'un PDG Citadella me prend sa retraite
pour la nouvelle compañía que son de Leon
tourne autour de l'action les retraités veulent que
Sears répare son déficit et ils veulent que
le gouvernement s'assure que le  l'entreprise
agit alors que la bataille s'intensifie Eddie
Lampert, l'actionnaire principal,
recrute un ancien employé
Brandon's transom pour prendre la relève, il
sera le dernier président de Sears Canada,
l'entreprise aurait-elle pu faire les choses
différemment, c'est une question tellement chargée
et vous savez que c'est une question chargée
question brins tous essaieront de faire l'
impossible
sauver une entreprise sur le point de mourir
il est le dernier espoir des retraités Hamilton
Ontario une ville qui a été construite sur l'acier
comme son père et son grand-père Scotch ont
même passé la majeure partie de sa vie dans ces
usines une fois ils '  j'ai embauché beaucoup de
gens ici c'était le pain quotidien de tout le monde
c'est la vie de notre famille
mais c'était un fragile sentiment de sécurité
formulaire du Vallon 20 000  euh les collègues de stell ont
dû se battre pour sauver leur
fonds de retraite après qu'il soit devenu déficitaire c'est le
truc de Josh c'est notre argent ils
ne devraient pas s'en aller avec et
généralement aussi des boucs émissaires du manque à gagner des
millions de régimes de retraite à prestations
déterminées détenus par des Canadiens sont à risque  pour
Scott D Val, l'histoire s'est répétée
trop de fois
en 2015, Sears était dans un gouffre financier
profond et les choses
empiraient. Le dernier président de Sears transyl de Brandon
dit qu'il a hérité d'une entreprise en difficulté.
l'entreprise
serait morte il n'y avait aucun moyen de financer
la pension et de financer l'entreprise et de
tout faire à ce moment-là vous
auriez dû le faire dans le passé
dans le passé Sears a profité des
mesures d'aide offertes par le gouvernement de l'
Ontario et  n'a pas entièrement financé la
pension alors que l'entreprise était rentable,
ces mesures étaient destinées à aider les
entreprises à faire face à la crise de 2008
et ont permis à Sear  s pour différer les paiements
à sa caisse de retraite
nous avons toujours suivi toutes les règles et nous nous
sommes assurés que tout était fait dans les
livres aujourd'hui c'est un bisou des années d'
opposants scalawags LC il avait une mère
autoritaire le conseil d'administration devait
équilibrer les intérêts opposés ceux des
actionnaires  contre ceux des retraités
mafia de satin jaune à Kokomo un
exemple advil vous manquez Califat si Atma
système juridique certaine forme vivacité Cal C
profit manager Ally a préféré mon moral
Dioner cart est une analyste financière indépendante
elle va encore plus loin je dirais
définitivement avant tout que Sears
parce que Sears est le promoteur du
régime de retraite à prestations déterminées et qu'ils
ont une obligation fiduciaire et que les administrateurs
ont une obligation de diligence dans le cadre de la common law au
Canada, mais il n'y a pas que Sears qui
aurait pu faire plus pendant deux ans et demi
cette année  Un groupe de retraités a tenté
sans relâche d'amener le
gouvernement de l'Ontario à intervenir si vous savez que Mlle
Dianna Cart ne comprend pas pourquoi le gouverneur de l'
Ontario  n'a pas agi Cisco est
également responsable a le même niveau
que l'obligation fiduciaire la Commission aurait
pu forcer Sears à combler le déficit dans
un e-mail aux chefs du Canada la
Commission était vague quant à la raison pour laquelle elle n'est pas
intervenue ils ont insisté pour que Sears
suive  les règles
en juin 2017, Sears avait peu d'options,
la société a déposé une demande de mise
en faillite dans l'espoir d'une restructuration,
mais cela a échoué et Sears a été contraint de
liquider quatre mois plus tard.
comme élimination de 20% Bakula mezack
el camino de la a la virge ou nvidia moi
personnellement mis en rémanence papa féministe
readin et Nia Beck donc le sort des
retraités de Sears ravive un vieux débat
actuellement le niveau universitaire peut s'adapter ou
non dans Maya protection la police a un
Le spécialiste du droit des traités de Yahoo Hassan Oprah
FFA Le Canada est en bas de la
liste des pays avancés lorsqu'il s'agit
de donner la priorité à ses retraités en cas de
faillite  cy les banques les avocats les comptables les
investisseurs et le gouvernement passent en premier
Je sais que les banques et les investisseurs veulent
s'assurer de leur chance après mais nous aussi
et le gouvernement devons prendre
position car les gens perdent
tout saint jésus Katja van le
retraité  un employé de telco essaie de résoudre
le problème aujourd'hui, il est un député néo-démocrate Criss
traversant le pays essayant d'obtenir un
soutien pour son projet de loi d'initiative parlementaire
le projet de loi veut que les retraités aient la priorité
dans les cas où les employeurs se restructurent ou
font faillite et cela met les retraités
par le bas  du totem au
sommet du totem qu'aucun argent ne peut
être versé car vous allez
déclarer faillite vous liquidez le régime de
retraite doit être en soie ce n'est pas la première
fois que les politiciens tentent de
modifier les règles fédérales sans succès dit
X  Le PDG de Sears, Mark Cohen, j'aurais
pensé de loin qu'après l'
effondrement de Nortel, le gouvernement
serait plus sensible à la
possibilité que ces parents  d de grande envergure alors
que ses échecs Dianne Urquhart s'est battue
pour changer la loi en 2010 après la
faillite de Nortel, les changements n'ont jamais été
adoptés en grande partie à cause de ce qu'elle
appelle l'industrie de la faillite, il y a
eu une opposition virulente de la part de l'Association des
banquiers canadiens, l'
Institut d'insolvabilité de  Le Canada et le conseil des
chefs de la direction objectent à l'
Iowa c'est Jeff Nantz ouais cet
employeur les deux propres Lafayette
bhiku TCU Fetzer épicentre des
acteurs nationaux brutaux
les banques pourraient menacer d'arrêter de prêter
aux entreprises en difficulté si elles ne sont pas
remboursées en premier  cas de faillite
mais nos deux experts pensent que pour se faire
rembourser les banques vont insister pour que les
entreprises remplissent leurs caisses de retraite
avant que les banques ne leur prêtent de l'argent pourtant une
place habituellement mise dans le cône vous serait
distribuée alors même que j'ai dit je veux épouser les
muets Matt luxe  tourisme Dorothea une nouvelle
ingenieur civil c'est l'esprit poesie a la
jolie qui Nancy donc j'ai bien demande au
premier ministre init  enquête menée
et s'engage à modifier
les lois sur l'insolvabilité et la faillite pour protéger les
travailleurs canadiens retraités et leurs familles oui
ou non jusqu'à présent, les lois restent
inchangées  le lobby de la faillite pour
Satan et la lave massive d'Ibuki Sabah
coupe pronto :
Pat's Liberals Canada auparavant en tant que
Preciado stell Co les retraités attendent toujours
de voir si leurs pensions
seront entièrement sécurisées l'entreprise
propose de financer le plan en vendant
des terrains industriels pollués
je n'ai pas '  Je ne pense pas que nous devions compter sur des
ordures pour financer nos régimes de retraite,
nous avons travaillé dur pour cela, ce n'était pas
censé être sur l'espoir sur certaines terres, les
retraités de Sears partagent les mêmes préoccupations pour
leurs futurs
actifs.  c'est un peu Sears qui a laissé tomber ses
retraités le dernier président de l'entreprise est
prudent je suis un
esprit financier très sophistiqué donc je comprends  et les
arguments que vous avez plus que quiconque
une richesse aiguë mais il refuse de
critiquer les décisions prises dans le passé
quelque chose que vous aimeriez dire aux
retraités, vous savez, je veux dire, j'ai travaillé
très dur pour amener cette entreprise à un
meilleur endroit c'était  exceptionnellement
difficile et c'était décevant pour
moi que nous ne l'étions pas que je n'étais pas en mesure
de vous apporter un meilleur résultat si je
m'asseyais devant eux c'est ce que je
dirais que l'actionnaire principal Eddie
Lampert nous a écrit en disant qu'il a toujours
cru en l'entreprise  survivrait il
dit qu'il n'est pas responsable des décisions
prises au Canada et qu'il n'a bénéficié directement que
d'une partie du
dividende bonjour
oui commissaire Lampert ed je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il ait engourdi les finances qui alter assure que
le tribunal a nommé un syndic pour
regarder  dans certains des milliards de
dollars de dividendes versés aux
actionnaires alors que l'entreprise était en
difficulté, les résultats de cette enquête
pourraient entraîner d'autres litiges,
la retraite de Sears  les ees avaient oui à dire leur
monde final